YONCA BRUNINI: Hello, everybody.
Yes.
Hello.
Good morning.
Wow.
Good turnout.
And I know we've got live
stream from offices across EMEA.
I'm very excited.
I'll just introduce
Arianna very quickly.
She needs no induction.
So I thought I'd say something-
a personal reflection
about Arianna.
As some of you know, because
I talk about it a lot,
I'm hugely passionate about
my family, the internet,
and I would put
like, sleep there.
And when I first
heard Arianna's talk,
"Sleeping Your Way to
the Top," how many of you
have heard about that?
I thought, she is amazing.
Not because the
way you turned it--
I think you were the first
person I heard talk about it--
but also because
as someone who's
quite passionate about sleep,
I find it's quite unpopular.
It's like, oh let's meet at this
time in the morning for a run.
Oh let's have another drink.
Let's have a meeting at
this time with the US.
I find that even in my personal
life, like my friends aren't
very pro sleep and so, it does
require a cultural change.
And I think Arianna's one of
the pioneers of that change.
Same goes for something
in my conversations
with my father about
what is success.
Switching to another topic
that needs a cultural change
and a rethink.
And I think Arianna's amazing
at thinking about these,
talking vocally about them
in a great storytelling way.
And so I'm very excited.
I know you all are.
So without any
further ado, Arianna.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Thank you so much.
I love having a fabulous Turkish
woman introduce a Greek woman
with a massive accent compared
to her very subtle kind
of little mysterious intonation.
Where is she really from?
With me, like is she Hungarian?
Is she Greek?
What is she?
So I am delighted to be here.
I love Google.
I love everything you're doing.
Including all your
wellness things,
your sleep pods, your
obsession with running,
your healthy snacks.
But you're right.
We'll talk about sleep.
There's some improvement that
is needed in that department.
But let's start with
the big picture.
Greek philosophers used
to ask three questions.
What do we need to know?
That was before
Google, when you had
to work hard to know things.
How do we govern the city?
And how do we live a good life?
And somewhere in the
last two centuries
we stopped asking
the last question.
And the good life became
reduced to the successful life.
And the successful life became
reduced to two metrics-- money
and power.
You know, slash
status, slash fame.
And trying to live a life based
on just these two metrics,
it's a little bit like trying
to sit on a two-legged stool.
Sooner or later, you fall off.
And that's why I wrote this
book to help us introduce
in our lives the third metric.
The third leg of the stool.
So it's not about denying
the first two metrics.
It's about adding a metric.
And that metric of four
pillars is very simple.
It starts with our
well-being in hand.
Because without our
health and well-being,
life is really not
the life we want.
Sometimes we are
forced to deal with it,
and with a lot of
lessons to be learned.
But 75% of health care
problems and costs
now are coming from
chronic preventable
a stress-related diseases.
So there's an element of health
and disease that we cannot
control.
But there's an awful
lot that we can control,
and that we are kind of
bringing on ourselves
in one way or another.
Because as Philippe [INAUDIBLE],
the Belgian philosopher put it,
burnout has become the
disease of our civilization.
And in the course of succeeding,
we have sacrificed our health.
Not perhaps when you are as
young as many of you here,
but we see you know, people in
their 40s and 50s with heart
disease, with the
high blood pressure.
And then the growing
increase of mental diseases,
of depression and anxiety.
Right now, one in
six in the UK is
suffering from some form
of depression or anxiety.
One in six.
So why, as a
civilization who've made
incredible strides in a solving
a lot of social problems,
and economic problems--
has a long way to go,
but has made huge progress--
we have really barely scratched
the surface of identifying
the inner causes of distress.
And what is exciting right
now, because I'm an optimist.
I'm a congenital optimist.
Partly because I'm Greek.
And partly because I'm
a naturalized American.
So it's a kind of irresistible
combo of optimism.
So my optimism comes
because right now we're
living in a perfect storm,
where a lot of trends
are converging to make
this an incredible moment
for the cultural shifts
that you talked about.
So the first trend is
the growing awareness
of all of the incredible
impact of burnout.
The second trend
is the new science
that is validating ancient
wisdom about the importance
of sleep, renewal, pauses in our
life to regenerate ourselves.
All those things that have
been dismissed as unnecessary,
all the language that
has been used, especially
by men-- none of the men
here, because they're all
enlightened-- but the men
who designed our world.
That we'll sleep
when we're dead.
Congratulating people
for working 24/7.
All these things that have kind
of been part of our culture,
that now we need to sort
of unravel and recognize
that they are really a delusion.
We now have a lot of science to
prove that they are a delusion.
That in fact, taking care
of our human capital,
nurturing ourselves,
unplugging and recharging
our own performance
enhancement tools.
They're not elements
of checking out.
Far from it.
They are the way to be most
effective and most creative.
And the other trend is that
now more and more people
are coming out of the closet.
Not out of the
closet saying they
are gay, although
that's happening too,
and it's safer and safer.
But coming out of the
closet and admitting
that they are
meditators, that they're
doing mindfulness courses,
and that they are actually
introducing these
elements into their lives.
And last year, 2013 was
the year when CEO after CEO
came out as being meditators.
Marc Benioff of
Salesforce told us
that he's been
meditating for 25 years.
Ray Dalio, the CEO of
one of the biggest hedge
funds, Bridgewater, said he's
been meditating for 35 years
and described it as the
foundation of his success.
So something happened where all
these things that before were
seen as a little flaky, a little
new agey, a little California,
are now seen as
safe to talk about,
and in fact, scientifically
validated as a great way
to lead and to
lead our own life.
So all this is in
the first pillar
of well-being and health.
The second pillar is wisdom.
You know, Google,
new technologies,
have made it possible for us to
have literally unlimited data,
to know everything.
But you haven't yet made it
possible for us to find wisdom.
And often, when
there's too much data,
it's harder and harder to find
the needle in the haystack.
So we need to tap
into our own wisdom.
And that's where we need
to remember that we all
have a place in us, which
is an incredible place
of inner wisdom, inner
strength, in inner peace.
But most of us don't live
there most of the time.
Nobody lives there all the time.
So life for me is a little bit
of a journey of how quickly can
we course correct.
How quickly can we
identify ourselves
being off center and
return to center?
If you think of it, we know
much more about our smartphones
then we know about ourselves.
We get alerts.
20% battery remaining.
17% battery remaining.
By about 13%, we get
anxious and we look around
for a recharging shrine.
Lest something would
happen to our smartphone.
We never say, you
know what, smartphone?
Deal.
OK?
Just get through it.
But we do say that to
ourselves all the time, right?
And when I collapsed, I start
my book, and I'm so glad.
Thank you so much for
getting copies for everybody.
So you'll see I start my
book with this episode
in my own life,
seven years ago when
I collapsed from exhaustion,
burnout, and sleep deprivation.
Hit my head on the way
down, broke my cheekbone,
got four stitches
on my right eye.
And as I look back, I must have
been below 0% battery remaining
and I didn't even know it.
I wasn't even aware of it.
So increasing that awareness
about our own state
of being makes it easier for us
to connect with our own wisdom,
connect with our own strength.
And let me just say,
this is important
whether you're at the
top of the world managing
multiple demands on
your time and attention,
or whether you're
just starting in life,
or whether you're struggling to
put food on the table, wherever
you are in life, when we
connect with that place, that's
when we connect
with our resilience.
And after all, whether you
succeed in life, in the bigger
sense of the word
or not, depends
on how easily
you're discouraged.
Because everybody has
failed along the way.
I have an entire
speech on my failures,
if you want to hear it.
Because very often when
people look at your success,
they don't know how many times
you failed along the way,
and I think that's
terribly unfortunate.
Because young people--
and I have two daughters
in their twenties-- need
to know that failure is not
the opposite of success.
It's a stepping
stone to success.
But what makes it
possible to accept
that is the fact that you
have your own resilience,
your own strength and peace
and wisdom that you tap into.
So that you're
not just dependent
on the outside
circumstances of your life.
One of the enemies of finding
our wisdom is multitasking.
And everybody here in
this room, including me
has really been brought
up in a new era thinking
that multitasking
enhances our productivity.
So I know you
Googlers love data.
So please look at the 45
pages of scientific endnotes
at the end of the book.
I put them there for you.
You don't have to believe
anything I'm saying.
Just look at the data.
There is no such
thing as multitasking.
It's task switching.
It's the most stressful
thing you can do.
And it robs you of the
ability to experience
that third dimension of wonder.
Because you know, life
is an incredible mystery.
And being connected
with the fact
that we're living in
an incredible mystery
is so important for
bringing joy into our lives.
And multitasking is
the enemy of that.
I live in New York.
And walking down the
streets of New York now,
you hardly see anybody who
is not either on the phone,
or worse, texting while walking.
And texting while
walking is seen
as a kind of badge
of importance.
Because you are so
important and so busy,
that you cannot just walk.
And so less important
and less busy
people need to get
out of your way.
Because they are
obviously just walking.
When I stopped multitasking
while I was walking,
I started noticing things
that I had not noticed before.
Next to my apartment there
is this beautiful building
with this incredible
ornamentation
at the top, which
I had never seen.
And I asked a friend, I
said, when did this go up?
And she said, 1890.
So what else are we missing
when we are constantly
buried either in our thoughts
or in our smartphones?
And being buried in our
thoughts is another issue
that we need to deal with.
That's what the whole
mindfulness practice is about.
It's about being
present right here.
Rather than lost
in our thoughts,
which are often either
judging us about what we did,
or judging somebody else, or
worrying about what's coming.
And our body-- again,
look at the science--
does not distinguish between
real things going wrong,
and our imagination and
our thoughts about things
going wrong.
As Montaigne, the
French philosopher
put it-- there were many
terrible things in my life,
but most of them never happened.
These are the kind of
negative fantasies.
I tell my daughters, never
lose in your own fantasies.
They're yours, make them good.
You know, don't
imagine the worst.
Incidentally, I don't
believe at all the idea that
imagine the worst because
if prepares you for it.
I don't believe that at all.
Because when
something bad happens,
and it happens in all our
lives, we are in a position
to deal with because
we are fully present.
Our mind, our emotions,
and our body in one place.
You can not deal
with something bad
when it hasn't happened yet,
except by stressing yourself
out.
And it's amazing just
reading the science
around how animals operate.
Gazelles are my screen saver.
They are kind of a
role model for me.
Because gazelles
really run really hard
when there's a danger.
When there's a lion or
a leopard chasing them.
But the minute the danger
passes, they graze.
And there's absolutely zero
stress in their system.
So that's really my
ideal state of being.
The equivalent for
us running hard
is we have a big
project to complete,
we have something to do.
We put 100% into it.
Then it's done.
But we keep staying in
a fight or flight mode.
And that's what
we need to change,
because we need to give
ourselves recovery time.
How healthy we are depends on
how much recovery opportunity
we give to our system.
And every religion and
every major philosopher
really talks in different
language about these pauses.
Those of you who have started
Japanese philosophy, zen,
or Japanese art, is
the concept of ma,
which literally means space.
And it's something sacred.
You know, bringing
space into your life,
pauses into your life,
the whole tea ritual,
whether in England, or much
more neutralized in Japan,
is about pausing.
And related to that
now is something
that we are all
engaged in, which
is innovation and creativity.
This is really
the supreme irony,
that our culture worships
innovation and creativity,
but we all live in a
way that completely
kills both of these things.
Because there's nothing worse
for innovation and creativity
then being perpetually
connected to our devices.
Because we're at the mercy of
incoming, what's coming at us.
So if you look at some
of the major discoveries,
whether it's Archimedes
while having a bath,
coming out and
shouting, Eureka .
And getting out naked, screaming
that he found his major love,
which would have been a great
tweetable moment, right?
You could just
imagine the retweets.
It would've been better
than Miley Cyrus twerking.
Or Newton, in a contemplative
mood in his garden,
and suddenly the apple falls.
And there's a lot of
literature about the fact
that he was in a
contemplative mood.
And when you saw
that apple falling,
he suddenly thought, why
is this all coming down
in a perpendicular way?
And the law of gravity was born.
So for those of us who worship
creativity and innovation,
we need to realize that time
famine, and time pressure,
and burnout really
are killing them.
And when we look at the
history of startups,
we know that startup
entrepreneurs are notoriously
sleep deprived and burning
the candle at both ends.
And we assume this
is the way to do it.
But then why do 3/4
of startups fail?
Maybe somebody here
should do a study
about the correlation between
sleep deprivation and startup
failures.
Because we really
need new role models,
and we need ruthlessly
to provide the evidence,
to eliminate the delusion, that
burnout is the way to succeed.
And I'm constantly in
search of new role models.
One of my favorites
is actually a woman.
Padmasree Warrior, who
is the chief technology
officer of Cisco.
And she oversees 10s of
thousands of engineers.
And she spoke at our
Thrive conference.
And she said, I sleep
for eight hours.
I meditate.
I write haikus.
I paint.
And every Saturday I
do a digital detox.
And she has a great role
model herself, which is God.
He worked very hard for six
days, created heaven and earth,
and he took a day off.
That's like, he did
a pretty awesome job.
I mean, there are few
imperfections here and there.
We're still in the better stage.
But nevertheless, this
is not just a fairy tale.
This is a very significant
story about the importance
of renewal.
And the final pillar,
well-being, wisdom, wonder,
is giving.
Because our culture
celebrates go-getters.
And very occasionally
celebrates go-givers.
We celebrate them around
Christmas and the holidays.
But in fact, we now
have the science
that shows that our genes
are wired for giving.
And when we give, all of the
inflammatory markers of disease
go down.
And giving is basically
a shortcut to happiness.
And there's great
neuroscientific evidence
out of the University of
Wisconsin about this, and about
the fact that happiness
is a learned skill.
Did you know that?
That you can learn to be happy?
We all think we can
learn to play tennis.
We can learn to play golf.
Whatever.
But we don't realize that
we also learn to be happy.
And the Greek word
for happiness,
in its most profound
sense, is [SPEAKING GREEK],
which translated
would mean thriving,
which is why I picked that word.
But in a literal
sense, it means--
and we have a fellow Greek
here who can correct me--
it means basically being at
peace with your own demons.
Because the Greeks realized that
ultimately, happiness is not
a function of external
circumstances,
It's a function of
our inner harmony,
with our external circumstances.
And some people are
infinitely dissatisfied,
no matter what they have.
Because somebody
else may have more,
somebody else always has more.
If you value your life just
in terms of these two metrics,
there is always
going to be somebody
who is beating you at the game.
I like to quote Mikhail
Baryshinikov, who said,
I don't try to dance
better than anyone else.
I just try to dance
better than myself.
And I think it's really
great whether you're
looking at your life, or
you're looking at your company.
At the Huffington Post, I tell
everybody, the most important
thing is for us to keep
disrupting ourselves.
To keep innovating.
It's not about what
anybody else is doing.
We're not competing
against anyone else.
And that is an incredibly
liberating way to look at life.
And I would love to see giving
time, volunteering, be part
of the way that we bring up
children from an early age.
Because I've seen the difference
it makes to my children
when they were young
and I had more control
over what they were doing.
And I would take them to
volunteer at places of art
with children, where
they could see and be
in touch with the suffering
in the world, which would make
them much less narcissistic,
and much less preoccupied
with everything
happening in their lives.
So these are the four
pillars of the third metric.
And because I very
much want the book
to be a bridge between knowing
what we should be doing
and actually doing it, I
have 12 steps in the book.
I picked 12
deliberately, because we
are addicted to our
current way of life.
12 steps, and you can pick
one step to start with,
whichever resonates
with you, to begin
to bring these
changes in your life.
And my first step was sleep.
I went from four to five
hours to seven to eight hours.
And as you said,
sleep deprivation
is being worn at the moment
like a badge of honor
by many people.
I had dinner recently with a
guy who bragged that he had only
gotten four hours
sleep the night before.
And I thought to myself--
I didn't say it--
but I thought to
myself, you know what?
If you had gotten
five, this dinner
would have been a
lot more interesting.
But we are all
operating from the sense
of time famine-- you
know, breathlessness.
A feeling that we just don't
have enough time to sleep.
I really just want
everybody to carefully look
at their discretionary time.
People have much more
discretionary time
that they think Somebody's
watching "House of Cards."
And that's why I really believe
in finding a thrive buddy.
Finding somebody in your
life who can support you,
and you can support them as
you are introducing new habits.
And let's say you are tempted
to binge watch "House of Cards"
at night instead
of going to sleep,
you can call your thrive buddy,
and they can cool you down.
They can tell you to
just take a deep breath,
and close your laptop, and you
can watch it over the weekend.
Because the point is that if
you don't get enough sleep--
you know that feeling of
being tired and walking around
like a zombie during the day?
I now really hate that feeling.
How many people are
sleep deprived today?
OK.
You don't have to be.
It's just a matter
of prioritizing.
Whatever it takes
to recharge you.
And how much sleep you
need is individual.
Most people need eight hours.
But whatever you need.
You know how you know it?
Because you wake up
without an alarm.
And another very important
step is at the end of the day,
turn off all your devices
and gently escort them out
of your bedroom.
Very important.
Because otherwise
you'll wake up and be
tempted to look at your data
if your smartphone is charging
by your bed.
And I know all your excuses.
Like, I need my smartphone
because it's my alarm clock.
OK.
First of all, if you put
it in the room next door,
you can still hear it.
Or you get a nice
vintage-looking alarm clock.
In the states, I give
them to all my friends
from Pottery Barn.
They're $32.
I'm sure you can find them here.
I think David Jones, I was
told, and Selfridges have them.
John, we should do a
little research for that,
so that we can advocate
where you can go and get it.
The point is don't allow
yourself to be tempted.
And I'm only going to
mention one more step that
was important to me, which
is at the end of the day,
scan your day and look at
something that you can drop.
That no longer serves you.
It could be a grudge,
a resentment, anger.
Just something.
Or it could be a
project that you thought
you were going to do, but
really you're not going to.
The latest project
that I've dropped
was becoming a good skier.
I decided that really
I was not going
to invest time and energy
into becoming a good skier.
And it was very
liberating to realize
that I could complete the
project by dropping it.
So as far as I'm
concerned, skiing is done.
When I go skiing with my
daughters or with friends now,
they ski, and I sit by the fire.
I drink hot chocolate,
and I read a good book.
And I'm very happy.
So just see what is it that
you're not really going to do.
And then you can really
invest your time and energy
into the things you
are going to do.
So let me wrap up so
that we can leave plenty
of time for questions by
saying that if we're alike,
you have 30,000 days to
play the game of life.
How we play depends
on what we value.
And if we only value
the first two metrics,
we're never really going to be
thriving, because we're always
going to be putting our life
on hold until we accomplish
something.
And then as soon as
we accomplish that,
we'll have another
goal, and we're
going to be putting
our life on hold again.
And basically we'll
be shrinking ourselves
down to our jobs
and our to-do lists.
And I just did an
interview with Oprah,
and she asks everybody the
same question at the end.
What do you know for sure?
And I said to her,
what I know for sure is
that however magnificent
your job is Oprah,
or however great my job is, or
however great anybody's job is,
who we are in our essence
is more magnificent.
We are more than our jobs.
And if you need
reinforcement of that,
just remember the last time
you were at a memorial service,
listening to a eulogy.
You know, our eulogies are very
different from our resumes.
Have you ever heard a
eulogy where they said,
George was amazing.
He increased market
share by one third.
So when we remember
all that, then we
can really find that place
that Archimedes called,
give me a place to stand,
and I can move the world.
We all have that place.
You know, we call it being in
the zone, being in the flow.
So we find that place.
And from that place
we live our lives
with more gratitude, more
creativity, more joy,
and yes, more sleep.
Thank you.
So who wants to come first?
If you don't mind coming
to the microphones,
because this is being streamed.
And also if you can tell me
your name, and what you do here,
and if you want, how
many hours sleep you get.
So who wants to go first?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi Arianna.
Thank you so much.
It's really, really inspiring
and very interesting.
My name is Gail.
I'm a director in the
sales team here as Google.
I'm actually also a mom of
two daughters, four and one.
I really would like
it if you could
have a chat with my
one-year-old at the moment,
about the sleep thing.
That would be really great.
But normally, I get
eight hours, because I
am a huge fan of sleep.
I really, totally agree
with what you're saying.
What I would really like to
understand from you is actually
as a working mom
yourself, if you
could have spoken to yourself
kind of, 15, 18 years ago
when your children
were really little,
what do you think you
would do differently?
And have you got any
advice for the working
parents in the room?
Because I think it's
not just a woman's role.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
That's a great question.
And so what I would
have done differently
is to be fully present
for my children.
Because when I look back,
I never missed a milestone.
You know, a performance,
or any school event,
although I never
baked the cookies.
And it's perfectly OK not
to bake the cookies, just
in case you are
guilty about that.
Because I really think when
they take the baby out,
they put the guilt in.
And every working
mother I know is guilty,
that she's not doing a good job.
So I would just
basically by practicing
the things I'm talking about
now, being recharged myself,
I would have been able
to be fully present,
instead of being
with them physically,
but my mind being
somewhere else.
Like, on what I was going to do
tomorrow, or what I didn't do,
or my completions, et cetera.
So that that's my
biggest advice.
And because I really think
that we miss so much.
And these are such
special years.
And even though,
I'm sure there are
times when your one-year-old
wakes you up at night.
It's just unbelievably adorable.
And there will be times
later in your life
when you would
like to spend more
time with that one-year-old,
but-- is it a boy or girl?
AUDIENCE: Girl.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: But
she will be awfully busy.
So treasure every moment.
And it's not easy.
No question about it.
That's why I'm a big
believer in naps.
And I'm glad you
have nap pods here.
Use them.
Use them liberally.
Because a 20 minute
nap, if you've
had a disruptive night of
sleep because of a young child,
or a sick toddler.
But a 20 minute nap, as
Winston Churchill famously
proved by calling
them power naps,
having them
regularly and winning
the war against Germany.
You can win any sales war
by recharging yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Hannah.
I work in the
sales finance team.
I was also very happy to hear
that you sleep eight hours,
because that's what
I try to do as well.
Something that you said that
really resonated with me
was that failures are stepping
stones to success, and not
the opposite of success.
Could you give an
example of something
that may have appeared like
a failure in your life,
but in fact it was just a
step to achieve success?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
Absolutely.
I mean for example, just to
start with my early years.
I went to Cambridge and I lived
in London for seven years.
And I wrote my first
book by accident.
I didn't want to be a writer.
I was actually going
to the Kennedy School
to do a post-graduate
degree in politics,
when I was asked by a
publisher who had seen me
on television at
Cambridge debate
to stop it to write a book.
So my first book did very well.
And then I wanted
to write a book
on the crisis in political
leadership, which
I wrote by spending--
I subsidized myself
by spending the money I had
made with my first book.
And that book was
rejected by 36 publishers.
And that's a lot of rejections.
And by rejection
36, I was thinking
that maybe this was the
wrong career for me.
That maybe my first
book was a fluke.
And I was walking down
St. James's Street,
despondent and then
having run out of money.
And I saw Barkley's
Bank, and I walked in.
And armed with nothing
but Greek chutzpah,
I asked to see the bank manager,
and I asked for an overdraft.
And for some reason,
he gave it to me.
I still send him a
Christmas card every year.
And that's something important
to remember during moments
of failure, when things
are not working out.
That we're not alone.
That it's a little bit
like in fairy tales,
when the hero or the heroine
is lost in the dark forest.
And all these helpful
animals come out
to help them find their way out.
When in life too, there
are helpful animals
disguised as human
beings, as bank managers,
there to help us.
And that's a very
important way to live life.
In fact, one of
my favorite quotes
in "Thrive," which I have
laminated in my wallet,
is from Rumi, the poet who said,
live life as though everything
is rigged in your favor.
So whatever happens, if
we can approach it from,
this is here to
teach me something.
In fact, there's an
incredible quote--
I'm going to give you a Cliff
note, page 118 of the book.
My favorite long quote-- too
long to read to you now--
by Marcus Aurelius, who
was a stoic philosopher
and the Emperor of Rome.
So the guy had a pretty big job.
And at the end of each
night, he would go to bed
and write what became his
famous book, "Meditations."
And in that book,
and in that quote,
he talks about how
everything that happens to us
has hidden blessing
and a hidden purpose.
And when we look at it that
way, life is transformed.
Because very often, a lot
of our pain and heartache
come from our attitude
to what happens to us,
rather than just from
what happens to us.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I'm Mark.
I work at YouTube.
Fascinating talk.
I can't wait to read your book.
I do have one question though.
So you spoke a little bit
about getting thoughts spiraled
in your head about
negativity-- building up
to scenarios that
actually never happen.
I know my family is
specifically guilty of doing
this kind of thing.
So I'm really interested in like
to hear from you, specific tips
or tricks to help people
to stop themselves
from getting into a place where
they start thinking like that.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
So first of all, if
we kind of recognize
that that voice
is not who we are.
And that's why I call it
the obnoxious roommate
living in my head.
And every time that
comes up, that voice, I
think a sense of
humor really helps.
And making it clear that
thoughts are not facts.
And thoughts are not you.
So there's that thing going
on, and if you approach it
like a sort of a toddler,
kind of screaming and being
disruptive, but it's not who
you are, and it's not fact.
It begins to weaken the
power it has on you.
I promise you, I had the most
obnoxious roommate living
in my head.
Very self- judgmental.
And now she only makes
guest appearances.
And so the energy that
became available to me
when that voice
subsided is amazing.
Because we look at the our
life in terms of time chunks,
but really it's
all about energy.
When you are operating
at 100% of your energy,
you can get stuff
done in one hour that
otherwise would take you a day.
And a function of
good energy isn't
just how much sleep we
get, or how rested we are.
It's also what we're
doing with our thoughts.
And what we're doing
with our minds.
But I promise you that you can
evict the obnoxious roommate
almost entirely.
AUDIENCE: Hi Arianna.
My name is Ioanna.
I am actually Greek as well.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Oh great.
AUDIENCE: And we
could do this in Greek
but it would be unfair.
Fascinating talk.
Thank you so much.
I guess what I
want to understand,
you mention something
about when we die,
what's going to be
on our deathbed.
And I thought about that a lot.
So even at university,
I remember thinking,
God I'm studying so hard.
But what if I die
tomorrow, what's the point?
I"ve missed a day.
What has driven you,
having that thought?
What currently drives you
to do all the other things
that you're doing, knowing
that at the end of it,
what really matters are love,
people, friendship, et cetera.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Great question.
First of all.
Having conversations about
that is incredibly important,
because our culture has
really driven death away
from our lives.
And in our Greek
culture, of course,
Socrates famously used to
say, practice death daily.
Not our of morbidity,
but because it
puts everything
else in perspective.
And now, all over Europe, and
now they've come to the states,
there are these death
cafes that have come up.
Where people can get together
and discuss their thoughts
about death.
There's another movement
called "Death over Dinner,"
when people get together, have
dinner, and discuss death.
And "The Onion," the humorous
magazine in the States
had a feature on death recently.
And the headline was, "Death
Rate Holds Steady at 100%."
So I think having that
realization and consciousness
then means that you really want
to focus on the things that
can make the most difference.
And for me, one of the
reasons why I love speaking,
say here to you about this,
is because I love the thought
that if enough of
us begin to bring
these changes into our
lives, we are going to really
very quickly reach
a critical mass.
And for those of you with
a scientific background
here, you know
that critical mass
is when there's enough
radioactive material
for the change to
become self sustaining.
So that's what we need here.
It's just enough people
introducing these changes
in our lives will make
this the new reality.
Right now we're like in
a period of transition.
Where there is a
global shift happening.
Thrive is part of
the global shift.
But if we can accelerate the
shift, then the current way
we live-- being hyper-connected
24/7, burning out,
perpetually stressed,
perpetually anxious,
is going to be seen
as barbaric And it's
going to be a
little bit like when
we moved from the Dark
Ages to the Renaissance,
when we stopped believing
that the Earth is flat.
And everything changes.
And I want to be alive
to see that change.
I think it's going
to be amazing.
And it's going to lead
to an incredible amount
of creativity, go-giving
and at every level,
we'll be able to deal
with our problems better.
Including at the
political level.
I'm speaking this afternoon
at the House of Commons,
where there's now a
mindfulness movement.
There are 97 members of
the House of Commons, peers
and staffers who have weekly
meditation and mindfulness
courses.
And if you look
around at the moment,
you see that our leaders,
most of our leaders,
are so mired in that
second metric of power,
that they are not able
to make good decisions,
because they look at
everything through that filter
of if this going to help
my reelection or not?
And not to mention the impact
of burnout on decision making.
It's so funny, because I was
speaking at the US Embassy.
And I said something
in my speech
about nap rooms in the
Embassy, and the Ambassador
said, that sounds
like a good idea.
We should do that.
And there's an article about
it in the Washington Post,
and the State
Department yesterday
felt that they had to put
a statement out saying
that nobody in the State
Department sleeps on the job.
It just shows how
archaic is our thinking.
And the spokeswoman said, she
understands the importance
of achieving work/life balance.
And one day she aspires to it.
And so basically,
she used the fact
that she doesn't have
work/life balance-- which
I think is a
terrible term, but we
know what she means--
as a badge of honor.
Hey, you know, I'm too busy
to worry about these things.
So this is the kind of thinking
that I want to make obsolete.
So I want it very soon to
be completely laughed at.
And I want politicians
who it's found out
that they have pulled
all nighters to then have
to do damage control about that.
Because we can't trust
their decisions as much.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I'm Zoe.
I work in the
marketing team here.
Thank you for coming in.
It was really inspiring.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I come
to talks like this,
and I think I'm going to
change something in my life.
And then real life
tends to get in the way.
So I was just wondering,
what are your tips
that you have about really
sticking to your principles
and making the change.
You mentioned the thrive buddy.
But do you tend to write
things down and review them
every so often?
How do you make them stick?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: So
the first thing-- and it
may sound counter-intuitive
is not to judge yourself
when we determine to do
something and we don't do it.
To just say, give
ourselves another chance
and another chance.
And to make the changes that
we start with very small.
Because especially
all these driven
A types here identify with that.
If we like something, and
we want to bring the change
we want to just
make them wholesale.
And then it becomes much
harder to implement.
And so just pick
something very manageable.
Just pick one thing.
Like I suggest getting
30 more minutes
sleep than you're getting now.
Or charging your phone
away from your bedroom.
Or making a gratitude list.
I think that's something
which is incredibly helpful.
And my daughter-- I write
about it in the book--
got involved in drugs in
her last year at college.
That was one of the heartbreaks,
the difficult moments
in my life in the
last two years.
She's now been sober and
went back and graduated,
and all is good.
But one of the things
that helped her a lot
was making this gratitude list
every night of three things
she's grateful
for, and sharing it
with two friends who shared
their lists with her.
And that begins to
get your mind trained
to focus on the good things.
Because we are trained to
focus on the bad things.
And that had some
survival benefit,
you now, because if, let's say,
we were pursued by a leopard,
and we focused on the
rainbow, we would be toast.
So but now, it's not just
focusing on the real dangers,
we focus on all those
imaginary dangers.
So learning to focus on things
that we are grateful for
is a great exercise for this.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arianna.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
Thank you so much for that.
I'm so pleased
that you mentioned
the giving side of things,
which I think is so important.
And I remember many years
ago, a mentor of mine
saying that you go
through stages in life.
You start with a learning phase.
And then and earning
phase, and a serving phase.
But he said, what if you could
do all three of those things
at the same time?
Which is something
I've been trying to do,
and I do a lot of
charitable work.
But at Google we
give time to people
to do serving things,
2 and 1/2 days a year.
And I was lucky enough to
go to Tanzania for 17 days
to do a volunteering
project recently.
Where we helped a rural
village to put a water
supply into place.
And it was an important
thing, because the villagers,
many women and
children are walking
for six to eight
hours a day to get
on bucket of not so clean water.
But I remember being in
the middle of that time
and thinking, this
isn't a scalable thing.
And I'm not really designed
to be digging and stuff.
Why don't I get a Bobcat,
or hire a digger to do this.
But we then spoke to the
chairman of the village,
and he said actually,
you know what really
made the difference to us
was that you were with us,
you were living
in the community.
You were working side
by side along with us.
And that really inspired us.
I think that the type
of giving that you give,
not just the money,
but your time
is quite an important thing.
But my question is, what
are other organizations
doing that you see
to really encourage
the right sort of giving
that really gives you
a lot of energy and makes
you feel a lot less stress.
What do you see?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So thank you.
That's a great point.
I see more and more
companies encouraging giving.
At the Huffington
Post, we, and at AOL,
which is our parent
company, we give three
paid days for volunteering.
And we match volunteer
contributions up
to a certain amount.
You see that happening
more and more
across the world
in many companies.
But also, as you
said, it's something
which we can take up ourselves.
Whatever our circumstances.
That is what is so interesting.
I have a story in the book
of a good friend of mine
who lost her job during
the financial collapse.
She had a big job in
investment banking.
She had never been out of work.
She was completely
undone by that.
And then I was talking to
her, and I said, you know,
this might be a
good time for you
to volunteer in this place
that is on the border.
A place for at-risk
children in Los Angeles,
called "A Place Called Home."
And she looked at me like
I had lost all empathy
and compassion.
And I said, you are going
to be looking for a new job.
But this is the first time
in your life you have time.
So you can give a
couple of hours.
And she did it.
And it is just transformational.
She was telling me
how first of all,
it put her own problems
in perspective.
She stopped feeling
so sorry for herself.
I really believe she
got another job faster.
But also she told me the
story of how every night they
would do a forgiveness circle.
And she was part of that circle.
And she forgave her daughter
for forgetting her birthday.
And the young woman next
to her forgave her father
for shooting her mother.
And that connected her with
a whole world out there.
Whether it's in Tanzania, where
people have to walk for hours
to get a bucket of
not very clean water.
Or whether it's in inner
cities, where people
are living at the mercy
of drive-by shootings
and real dangers.
It takes us away from our own
narcissistic preoccupations,
and our own questioning our
bodies, and our accents,
and our clothes, and our
place in the pecking order.
AUDIENCE: My question if about
awareness about well-being.
So you mentioned
how to recognize
your batteries being drained.
Do you have any
tips around that?
Because I feel like
most people in this room
probably tend to think,
I'll go hard for a week.
And then it'll be OK.
And the week becomes
a month, and so on.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
Absolutely.
First of all, what happens
is that the more recharged
you are, the sharper
your awareness gets.
So you begin to notice any kind
of departure from the center.
I was talking to a
pilot friend of mine,
who said to me that
airplanes fly off course
most of the time.
The reason that there
aren't more accidents
is because they have an
impeccable course correcting
mechanism.
So little by little,
your mechanism
of noticing these things
becomes truly impeccable.
And it's a matter of
where do you start?
How recharged are you?
And I find that the minute
I feel stress rising,
or tiredness, there are lots
of little keys in the book
that you can practice.
One is your breath.
Your breath is an
incredible recharging tool.
So wherever you are.
You can just focus
on your breath.
Breathing deeper.
Exhaling deeper.
Nobody else needs to notice it.
I do it regularly in
boring board meetings.
You know, I'm moving
to deep breathing.
And also the other thing you
can do is, look at your schedule
immediately, and see is there
anything here that I can drop?
Is there something
I can do without?
Is there a meeting
that is one hour
that I can make half an hour?
And I try as much as possible
when it's not pouring rain,
to have walking meetings.
Especially if it's one on one.
It's just great to just
go for a walk, which
is much more recharging.
Depending on where you
are and what's possible,
I think our awareness
increases every time we do it.
It's like building a muscle.
The more we do it, and the
more we pay attention to it.
Because now many of us don't
pay attention to it at all.
I had a young woman
in San Francisco who
came to me after
my speech and said,
I don't remember the last
time I was not tired.
So many of us have
been in that state.
So it's like building
a new muscle.
And then it becomes
easier and easier.
I want to thank you so
much for being here.
For taking this time out
of your very busy lives.
And I want to invite you to
continue this conversation
on the Huffington Post.
Because I feel
one of the ways we
can have people bring these
changes in their lives
without having their own
painful wakeup calls, as I did,
or worse, is to learn from
the wakeup calls of others,
and to learn from the
thriving recipes of others.
So I'm going to give you
my email address, which
is Arianna-- with one R and
two Ns-- @huffingtonpost.com.
And if there's anything
you want to write about,
please send it to me.
And also we have a campaign we
launched, hashtag how I thrive.
So if you have anything
you do in your life that
helps you thrive, share it
with others, because you never
know who else may be inspired
and may want to do it too.
Thank you.
And thank you so much.
YONCA BRUNINI: Thank you.
I just want to say,
reflecting on what you said.
When I was being present
and reflecting on wonder,
I mean, it is really
amazing to have you here
to talk to us about
this in person.
So I really want to
thank you for that.
And in your words
of giving, we could
do the gift of giving by telling
more people about this book.
Google plus-ing,
YouTubing, right?
Tweeting about it.
So give the gift of
Thrive to everybody
you know after you've read it.
And thank you so much.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
Thank you.